ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะครูฟ้า
คุยวันนี้วันอะไรคะเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะได้ค่ะ
คุณ
เอาสีอยู่ไหนอ่ะ
โอเคไหมโอเคจะหาสีไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไรนะคะอ่ะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์
นี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนอ่า
พฤษภาคมดีผชอะไรคะปีพต 2
4  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
เปล่าเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
ศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
13 ค่ะเดือนเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีพ
2022 ค่ะเปล่าพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนเดือน
อาตีพ.ต.ท.ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 หากตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
เที่ยง
เที่ยงกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า 8 นาทีค่ะคือหญิง
เตียง
8 นาที
เที่ยงแล้วเป็นเวลากลางวัน
เป็นเวลากลางวันครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังคะ
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะผู้หญิงนิ
ทำไมกินข้าวแล้วแต่หน้ากรูฟ้ามีความสุข
มากๆ
เพราะว่าครูพาได้กินอาหารแต่พี่ชอบอ๋อ
เป็นอาหารที่ชอบที่ชอบเนี่ยนะคะเป็นอาหาร
จานโปรดของครูฟ้าไหมเป็นอาหารจานโปรดของ
ภูฟ้าค่ะคลีวิ่งอะไรคะครูฟ้า
อะไรหรอ
ตายยากรู้ว่าอาหารจานโปรดของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อะไรเธอ Fast ปอบกินอะไรมากๆ
เอาอาหารจานโปรดก่อนนะจ่ายค่ะได้ๆมันมา
อาหารจานโปรด
นี่หา
อ๋อ
ข้าวไข่เจียวข้าวไข่เจียวปลาชอบ How ไข่
เจียวมากค่ะอ๋อแล้วเข้าไข่เจียวเนี่ยเป็น
อาหารจานโปรดของครูฟ้า
คุณครูฟ้ากินจากร้านอาหารร้านโปรดของครู
ฟ้าไหม
อาร์ม
ไม่ใช่ใช่ไหมไอ้ห่าไม่ใช่
แล้วครูฟ้ามีร้านอาหารร้านโปรดไหมมีค่ะ
ร้านอาหารร้านโปรดของครูป๊านะคะก็คือทำ
อะไรนะที่จะเป็นร้านโปรดของครูฟ้า
นี่หา
กูจิ
Restaurant
ร้านอาหารร้านโปรดเป็นอาหารญี่ปุ่นเหรอคะ
เป็นร้านอาหารญี่ปุ่นเป็นร้านอาหาร
ญี่ปุ่นที่แม้มีฟูจิฟูจิ
แล้วในร้านฟูจิมี
เมนูโปรดของครูฟ้าไหมอยู่ในฟูจิเมนูโปรด
ของครูฟ้านะคะมีค่ะฟ้าถ่ายรูปไว้เยอะ
หนึ่งไม่ต้องหาในอินเตอร์เน็ตเลยเป็นเมนู
โปรดจริงๆอะไรคะอะไรคือเมนูโปรดใน
อะไรอ่ะฟ้าเห็นค่ะ
แซลมอน
เป็นเมนูชื่ออะไร
ข้าวหน้าแซลมอนโอ๋เป็นเมนูโปรดได้ยินไหม
คะเป็นเมนูโปรดเมนูโปรดของครูฟ้าเสียงผู้
หญิงมันแปลกๆนะคะอ้าวหรอคะใช่ค่ะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นอาจจะอินเตอร์เน็ตไม่ค่อยโอเคนะครับ
ฝนจะตกแต่นักเรียนอาจจะดูโอเคนะเพราะผู้
หญิงเป็นเป็นซูมกูหญิงแก่ผู้ฟ้า
อินเตอร์เน็ตดีโอเคแล้วค่ะโอเคค่ะอ่ะของ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยฟูจิเป็นร้านอาหารร้านให้โหลด
และข้าวหน้าแซลมอนเป็น
มีโปรดโรแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงมีร้าน
อาหารร้านโปรดไหมมีค่ะครูฟ้ามีค่ะร้าน
อาหารร้านโปรดของครูหญิง
คือกินอะไรเห็นไหมเห็นค่ะร้านเนี่ย
อันนี้เป็นร้านนะคะชื่อร้านจะเป็นภาษาไทย
น้องนักเรียน
ค่ะ
นี้นะค่ะร้านชื่ออะไรคะแม่ศรีเรือนแม่
ศรีเรือนหรอก็เป็นร้านอาหารไทย
ชาย
ดังน้อเป็น
ร้านอาหารโปรดของครูหญิงคะใช่ค่ะเป็นร้าน
อาหารโปรดของครูหญิงแล้วก็ผู้หญิงมีเมนู
โปรดในร้านนี้ด้วยนะครูฟ้า
เมนูโปรดในร้านนี้คือคืออะไรคะผู้หญิงนี่
ค่ะก๋วยเตี๋ยวไก่ก๋วยเตี๋ยวไก่ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ไก่
ตายร้านอาหารแม่ศรีเรือนเนี่ยเมนูโปรดที่
ครูหญิงชอบกินก็คือก๋วยเตี๋ยวไก่
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวไก่ใช่เขาทีว่าก๋วยเตี๋ยวไก่
ทรายครูผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบไปกินแม่ศรีเรือน
ที่เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์เวลาครูหญิงคิดอยากจะไป
ดูหนังสมัยดูหนังอ่ะ
ใช่ค่ะก่อนดูหนังก็จะไปกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวไก่
สมัยเมนูโปรดอ่ะก็พูดถึงดูหนังครูฟ้า
ดูหนังเรื่องโปรดไหมคะที่ครูอาร์มมากๆ
นั่งเรื่องโปรดละฮะ
มีค่ะคู่หญิงไหนไม่ต้องโกรธของครูฟ้า
เรื่องอะไรคะ
เรื่องนี้เลย
ไหนโอ้อันนี้เป็นหนังไทยหนังฝรั่งหนังจีน
หนังไทยค่ะหนังไทยชื่ออะไรคะหนังเรื่อง
โปรดของครูฟ้าน่ากดผิดตั้งนา
ชื่อสิ่งเล็กๆที่เรียกว่ารักอ๋อ Viva  any
ชื่อภาษาอังกฤษนะภาษาอังกฤษชื่ออะไรอ่ะลิ
รตติง
อะ Little  things
ผมขอว
[เพลง]
สโตนนะเป็นหนังเรื่องโปรดของครูหญิง
นึ่งใช่ไหมผู้หญิงตายแต่เวลาที่เราดูหนัง
เนี่ยอย่าง Harry  Potter หนังเรื่อง
แฮร์รี่พอตเตอร์ก็จะมีดาราหนังใช่ไหมคน
นี้เนี่ยคนที่เล่นเป็นแฮร์รี่เนี่ยเป็น
ดาราวันนี้ก็เป็น dara  dara  dara  dara
dara งาสมัยดาราแล้วก็มันแอ็คสั้นเล่น
เป็นแฮร์รี่
ดัมเบิลดอร์เฮอร์ไมโอนี่รอนโปรเฟสเซอร์
snape แม็กบอนอาการก็จะมีกะดาราใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยอุ้ยกดผิดครูฟ้ามี
ดาราคนโปรดไหม
ดาราคนโปรด
มีผู้ชาย
ควีนฟ้ามีทั้งผู้ชายและผู้หญิงหรอคะใช่
ค่ะครูหญิงดาราคนโปรดผู้ชายของคุณฟ้าเป็น
ดาราเกาหลีอ่ะชื่ออะไรคะคนนี้
ครีมซอนโฮท้องขอดาราผู้ชายแล้วดาราผู้
หญิงคนโปรดของครูฟ้าล่ะคะ
ก็เป็นคนเกาหลีคนโปรดของคุณฟ้าชื่อฮันทะ
โยจูผู้หญิงก็ชอบคนนี้คนเกาหลีดาราเกาหลี
หญิงสาวคนนี้เหมือนกันน่ารักชอบมากนะคัน
ถ้าดาหรอกโปรดเป็นดาราคนโปรดของครูฟ้า
ไอห่าแล้วครูหญิงหรอคะมีดาราคนโปรดไหมนี้
นี้นาครูหญิงมีดาราคนโปรดเนี่ยแต่ว่าเป็น
ผู้ชายนะอยู่ไหนล่ะอะกูไม่รู้กูฟ้ารู้จัก
หรือเปล่าคือเป็นดาราคนโปรดตอนนี้
in  the  future นะเปลี่ยนตลอดเวลานี่
ค่ะดาราคนโปรดของครูหญิงคู่ฟ้ารู้จักไหม
คะไม่ค่ะใครคะผู้หญิงเขาชื่อว่าออสการ์
ไอแซคมหาตอนนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงบีซีรีย์
เรื่องโปรดก็คือมูนไนท์
หมู่ไหนน้องเป็น Marvel  characters แล้ว
คนนี้นะคะออสการ์เนี่ยเขาเล่นเป็นมูนไนท์
ในคุณก็คิดตอนนี้เป็นดาราคนโปรดของครู
หน้าที่เป็นผู้ชายส่วนผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงเป็นดาราไทยนะคะคนนั้นเป็นอเมริกา
เนาะผู้ค้าหรอไม่ใช่ค่ะจะแต่นักเรียนจะดู
รูปไหนดีคะจะได้รู้สึกถ้าเธอเป็นเขาอะไร
เงี้ยอันนี้ละกันนะคะ
ญาญ่า
ตายเป็นดาราไทยหรอชื่อญาญ่านะคะผู้หญิง
หญิงชอบคนนี้เป็นดาราคนโปรดของครูหญิงนะ
เอ้อมีดาราแล้วก็ต้องมีนักร้องเรื่องนั้น
ๆนักร้องคนโปรดผู้หญิงมีคนเดียวและนัก
ร้องคนโปรดของครูฟ้าคือใครคะ
เป็นนักร้องคนโปรดไม่ได้เพราะเขาก็เป็น
นั่งร้องโอดล่ะไปกันนะเขาเป็นเองเป็นวง
โปรดของครูฟ้าวงแต่ว่าคนนี้เป็นนักร้อง
แล้วก็จะมีกีตาร์เบสอย่างเงี้ย
เป็นวงแทททูคัลเลอร์เป็นไทยนะคะนักร้อง
ไทย Thai  man  Show
เสือโคร่ง not แต่นักร้องคนโปรดของครู
หญิงเนี่ยเป็นนักร้องเดี่ยววก็คือร้อง
เพลงคนเดียวกูฟ้ารู้จัก
ไปคะผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงแชร์รูปนะคะนี่นี่ค่ะคนนี้คือนัก
ร้องคนฟรีของครูหญิงกูชอบมากเลยตอนเด็กๆ
มาลองได้จ่ายค่ะ Taylor  Swift นะคะเป็น
นักร้องคนโปรดของครูหญิงมีนักร้องนักร้อง
ร้องเพลง
เพลงโปรดของเรา
เพลงโปรดของครูฟ้าครูฟ้ามีไหมคะเปิดถ้า
เราเปิดเนี่ยไม่ได้ล็อคบล็อคกูให้ดูอะ
เปิดรูปชื่อเพลงให้ดูก็ได้ค่ะว่า Green
ก่อนแล้วกันนะภูพระหาอยู่ผู้หญิงดีขึ้น
แล้วอ่ะของครูหญิงนะคะตอนนี้ก็คือเพลงนี้
at  My  Word นะคะ at  My  Work นักร้อง
ก็คือ
Pink  Sweet  in ไม่แน่ใจอ่านว่าอะไร
Pink เป็นชายค่ะ at  My  Work เป็นเพลง
โปรดของครูหญิงนะคะผู้หญิงเนี่ยมี YouTube
1 ชั่วโมงเพลงนี้
แล้วก็คือ
ใช้ฟังฟังฟังฟังฟังหน้าเป็นเพลงโปรดของ
ครูหญิงค่ะแล้วเพลงโปรดของครูฟ้าเพลงอะไร
คะ
อ๋อก็เป็นของนักร้องวงโปรดใช้ tattoo
colour รักแรกพบนะคะรักแรกพบว่าชอบมาก
หนูก็เลยเป็นเพลงโปรดของครูฟ้าเนาะจะช่วย
กันเลยไม่ใช่เขามีดารารักร้องเพลงแล้วผู้
หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนชอบการ์ตูน
ซอยกูหญิงกับกูฟ้าเนี่ยก็จะมีหนังสือเนาะ
หนังสือการ์ตูนสมัยหนังสือการ์ตูนดาราเทา
ดูการ์ตูนก็จะต้องมีการ์ตูนตัวการ์ตูนตัว
โปรดของเราที่เราชอบมากๆครูฟ้ามีไหมฮะผู้
หญิงมีตัวอะไรนะผู้หญิงตัวการ์ตูนตัวโปรด
ของผู้หญิงคือตัวการ์ตูนจริงๆผู้หญิงมี 2
ได้ไหมมีพิมมีตัวเดียวนะคะตัวการ์ตูนตัว
โปรดเอานี้ละกันนะคะตัวการ์ตูนตัวโปรดของ
ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ก็คือตัวนี้เอาคลุมบ้ากับทีโมนอาจาด Lion
King ไลน์ให้ดูนะมาทาไปถึงไหนเท่านั้น
เองเคยดูอะไรอ้อนคิงนานก็เลยเป็นแบบตัว
การ์ตูนตัวโปรดของครูหญิงนะครูฟ้า PEA
ไหมมีหานี้หากผู้หญิง
สติ๊สราคุยไม่รู้หรอกนะผู้หญิงอาจจะกูฟ้า
กูเกิลเสิร์ชอ้าวผู้หญิงติซจากลีโล่แอนด์
สติทช์มั้ยคุยชอบสับสนกับทิปกับ Dell มัน
จะมีชิป
this เป็นการ์ตูนการ์ตูนตัวโปรดเออเวลา
มีการ์ตูนเนี่ยบางครั้งมันก็จะมีตุ๊กตากู
ฟ้ามีตุ๊กตาตัวโปรดมาไหมตุ๊กตามีค่ะ
ได้ค่ะ
ได้ๆอ้ะเพราะว่าเวลาชิเราดูการ์ตูนใช่ไหม
กันอุ้ยการ์ตูนก็จะมีตุ๊กตาสมัยนี้เป็น
การ์ตูนเหมือนกันนะนี่ก็เป็นการ์ตูน
monster  in สมัยก็จะอ่าตุ๊กตาแต่ว่าครู
ฟ้ามีตุ๊กตาตัวโปรดใช่ไหมคะ
ก็ตาของกูปลานะคะ
ตุ๊กตาเป็นตุเป็นตัวอะไรนะเป็นเสือชีต้า
สีหน้า
เสือชีต้าร์ใช่ค่ะอันนี้เป็นตุ๊กตาตัว
โปรดของครูฟ้าแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะมีมั้ย
ตุ๊กตาตัวโปรดนี่เลยคะครูฟ้าสีฟ้ามีผู้
หญิงก็มีค่ะนี่เลยอุ้ยโต๊ะ
ตัวอะไรคะเบบี้โยดาค่ะหรือว่า The ชายตา
วอน้องเป็นตุ๊กตาตัวโปรดของครูหญิงตอนนี้
นะคะตุ๊กตายัดตา Water  Man  The โรเรียน
นะคะเออนี่แหละก็เวลามีตุ๊กตาตัวโปรดแล้ว
ก็คุยอีกเนี่ยชอบกลุ่มบ้ากับทีมถ้าจะให้
พูดบ้างกับกี่โมงเนี่ยเป็นการ์ตูนใน Lion
King ว่าแล้วก็ใน Lion ผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบ
Lion  King เราก็มีเสื้อเสื้อเสื้อที่
เป็นอันนี้เด่นมินนี่เม้าส์ใช่ไหมอันนี้
เป็นเสื้อที่เป็น Lion  King ซึ่งเป็น
เสื้อตัวโปรดของครูหญิงตอนนี้ครูฟ้าไหนคะ
เสื้อตัวโปรดของผู้หญิงไม่ออกนะนี่ 5
เห็นไหม Lion  King เนาะเป็นเสื้อเสื้อ
ฮู้ดละเสื้อมีฮู้ดแขนยาวนานแล้วก็มีอะไร
อ้อนคิงเป็นเสื้อตัวโปรดของครูหญิงใส่
บ่อยๆประเทศไทยร้อนก็ใส่ว่าเป็นเสื้อตัว
โปรดครูฟ้ามีไหมเสื้อตัวโปรดเหมือนกันเลย
ค่ะผู้หญิงแต่ว่าไม่ได้แบบนั้นลูกค้ามี
เสื้อตัวโปรดค่ะเสื้อตัวโปรด
เออเดี๋ยวกูฟ้าประเทศไทยหนาวหรอ
ซื้อคอเต่าได้แล้วดู
เพลงอันนี้คือคอแล้วก่อนครูฟ้าไปออฟฟิศ
ใส่บ่อยๆผู้หญิงก็คิดตัวนี้มันเสื้อตัว
โปรดครูฟ้าหรือเปล่าๆมาชอบมากนะจึงมีสี
ขาวสีส้มสีฟ้าสีชมพู
สาย 4
ใช่แต่ว่าประเทศไทยราะร้อนจะใส่ก็เป็น
เสื้อตัวโปรดของเราไง
ตัวโปรดมาใส่บทก็
ทรายเวลาใส่เสื้อก็ต้องมีรองเท้าไอ้หนึ่ง
อย่างแล้วเนาะรองเท้า by ผู้มาหามาแล้วนะ
รองเท้าคู่โปรดครูหญิงนี้ให้นักเรียนดู
แต่ว่าขอโทษไว้ก่อนเลยนะคะคนไทยจะไม่ทำ
เนาะแต่นี่เป็นคลาสนะคะค่ะ
อีกนิดหน่อยนะคะนักเรียนเพราะว่าเป็นรอง
เท้าคู่โปรดแล้วเนี่ยจะรู้สึกผู้หญิงชอบ
Nike ใช่ไหมคะไม่บอกไม่รู้นะคะแต่รอง
เท้าคู่โปรดของทรูหญิงเนี่ยเป็น Adidas
Superstar
นี้นิแท็บแถบสีดำอันนี้เป็นรองเท้าคู่
โปรดของครูหญิงรักมากๆนะคะ
โกรธไม่ได้นะคะว่าเหม็นนะคะครูซะมีรอง
เท้าคู่โปรดไหม
กูพาชอบ Convert ค่ะ
Converse เป็นรองเท้าคู่โปรดของครูฟ้า
คอนเวิร์สสีขาวเลย
กูบ้าให้รู้ไม่ได้นะคะเพราะตอนนี้ Convert
to ฟ้าเนี่ยสีดำ
ใจเรียนนั่นแหละแล้วนักเรียนมีไหมอ่าของ
โปรดของโปรดหน้าของที่นั่งเรียนโปรดก็คือ
ดีมากๆเลยค่ะนั้นไม่ว่าจะเป็นเสื้อผ้า
เสื้อตัวโปรดรองเท้าคู่โปรดดารานักร้อง
เพลงโปรดนะคะนักเรียนมีไหมชอบเรื่องอะไร
มากๆคอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้
นะคะครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ไปก่อนเนาะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ